bonjour christelle père était merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors votre syndicat entre autres
appellent à une grève illimitée alors
vous êtes contre l'obligation vaccinale
n'est pas contre le vaccin c'est ça on
reste sur le principe que la vaccination
doit être quelque chose de volontaire de
libre et éclairé c'est le principe c'est
un principe constitutionnel d'ailleurs
dans vos dans vos commentaires il ya eu
un certain nombre de deux syndicats qui
le relève que l'armée contre entre le
principe constitutionnel avec des
atteintes graves qui fait d'ailleurs que
la cgt avec solidaires et fsu ont déposé
à une saisine au conseil constitutionnel
sur les la vaccination sur le fait que
soient transgressés l'égalité
l'interdiction de discrimination que le
droit au travail aussi soit atteint dans
cette obligation vaccinale qui est en
plus l'histoire de ne pas rémunérer donc
de suspendre sans rémunération les
soignants qu'on ne seraient pas vaccinés
donc c'est vrai que c'est assez c'est
assez compliqué donc oui la cgt a déposé
un préavis de grève illimitée
effectivement c'est il ya beaucoup de
syndicats qui ont commencé par le faire
et bien évidemment on en est à un
syndicat qui est formé de de ses
syndiqués de ces syndicats de base et
donc qui suit qui suit bien évidemment
ce qui est fait donc la corse quand vous
avez dit marseille lyon montpellier
l'ap-hp qui vient déposer un préavis à
partir du 9 août illimité donc bien
évidemment que la cgt ne ne peut pas
rester sans son sens en faire un appel
national par rapport à tout ça c'est la
réponse à la demande et des personnes de
terrain une grève alors quand on parle
de grève à l'hôpital c'est surtout tout
ce qui est administratif qui est qui est
stoppé bien sûr
voilà le le soin qui a été apporté aux
malades continuent et continuent bien
évident parce qu'à des réquisitions
certes mais ça veut dire que forcément
les services vont fonctionner encore
plus en sous-effectif cette histoire de
vaccination des obligations vaccinales
pour les soignants ça pose quand même un
énorme problème de contradictions en
fait ça fait un an et demi que les
hospitaliers quels qu'ils soient verts
parce que vous parlez des administratifs
et des soignants mais moi je mets tout
le monde de manière identique les
soignants de les soignants et les
administratifs les hospitaliers en
général ça fait un an et demi qu'ils
sont malmenés si l'iran leur a demandé
de venir travailler sans protection sans
on leur a même demandé de venir
travailler en étant en étant positif au
co vide il faut pas l'oublier
et puis aujourd'hui on va leur dire de
ne pas venir travailler on va leur
imposer de ne pas venir travailler alors
qu'ils sont pas forcément porteur c'est
à dire que simplement par le fait qu'ils
ne seront pas vaccinés on va interdire
leur travail et on est dans une espèce
de contradiction extraordinaire parce
que là on nous annonce une quatrième
vague avec avec un besoin en personnel
important personnel qu'on va les laisser
chez soi vous voyez bien qu'il ya
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas on a
tout misé sur sur un vaccin actuellement
qu'on veut imposer aux gens alors que ce
fait des années et des années que les
personnels des hôpitaux demandent une
augmentation des effectifs voit bien
qu'il ya des choses qui vont se préparer
et qui vont qui vont arriver et s'était
déjà dit s'il y avait des pandémies on
serait on serait très embêté on le voit
déjà
ne serait-ce que les hivers avec la
grippe ça fait des années des ziani
qu'avec la grippe on manque de personnel
on manque de lits on manque de place
dorée à mais on continue on continue
hélas aujourd'hui il ya dire au
personnel vous avez été vous a été
présent pendant toute la première
période c'était très bien
on vous a obligé à travailler en étant
porteur du pôle iiid vous obliger à
travailler sans être protégé on ne vous
a pas reconnus en maladie
professionnelle
si vous avez attrapé les pots vides
pendant votre service sur soi à être
décédés ou avoir une oxygénothérapie et
aujourd'hui on va leur dire venez pas
travailler vous n'êtes pas rémunérer le
personnel soignant a toujours été en
première ligne depuis l'apparition du
coc vite dit
9 on sait qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
syndicats s'inquiètent également des
conséquences de cette obligation
vaccinale sur le moral des soignants
même après la première vague beaucoup
avaient décidé de quitter leur poste à
l'hôpital car il était
fatigué psychologiquement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui cette obligation
vaccinale pourrait entraîner des
démissions avec force le clairement au
mois de février 2021 avant l'obligation
vaccinale on était déjà à plus de 10000
démission dans les hôpitaux
est-ce qu'on a les moyens au niveau de
l'état de santé en france des systèmes
de santé de se priver de ces personnes
et là effectivement il ya des personnes
qui commença à parler de poser des
démissions effectivement mais aussi des
disponibilités pour laisser passer cette
obligation
il ya des gens qui ne veulent pas se
faire vacciner il pour autant continue à
très bien appliqué les gestes barrière
qui sont quand même la première des
choses pour pour éviter les pour éviter
les contaminations qui qui porte les
protections nécessaires et aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya des personnes qui
parlent de quitter l'hôpital mais pas
que l'hôpital parce qu'il ya même au
niveau des professionnels libéraux
si vous regardez un petit peu ce qui se
passe là vous êtes des professionnels
libéraux qui refusent les injonctions à
la vaccination et qui disent tant pis
tant pis un métier que j'aime et faire
c'est un métier que j'avais choisi de
faire en libéral et ben j'arrête
eh bien on a des personnes des hôpitaux
merci beaucoup en tout cas christelle
pernette d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes ergothérapeute
et militante syndicale à la cgt